[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday september 12th i'm julie chang
for the wall street journal filling in
for zoe thomas
the people who swap stocks on robin hood
aren't always the same as traditional
traders they're younger for one robin
hood says the average age of its users
is 32 and they aren't necessarily
interested in the same stocks as the
pros on wall street
but there's more than 22 million of them
according to the company
and their trades move markets and now
robin hood has created its own index
showing the stocks its users are most
excited about
among them tesla apple amazon and ford
meme stocks like amc and gamestop and
the chinese electric car company neo so
what else can this new index tell us
about how people are using robinhood
here to explain is wsj markets reporter
alexander ossipovic alex thank you so
much for coming on the show thanks for
having me
so can you start us off by telling us
more about this new index what exactly
has robin hood created here so robin
hood has created something that it is
calling the robinhood investor index
it is an index like the dow jones
industrial average or the s p 500
but instead of trying to track a broad
swath of stocks in the stock market it
will track the top 100 stocks that are
popular among robin hood investors
the way that they're constructing this
is that they're looking across their
user base which involves millions of
users
and identifying the stocks in which it
says that customers have the most
conviction what that means is how much
of your portfolio percentage-wise have
you allocated to a particular stock so
if you put 50 of your stock in gamestop
and a lot of other people have done the
same thing gamestop will rate highly in
this index uh it's a bit different from
the way some other indexes are
constructed and it is notable because
many consumers on robinhood don't
actually have that much money in their
accounts they might have as little as 20
worth of stocks in their account and
their commitment to a particular stock
would still be noted
by this index one other thing that's
important to note about the robinhood
investor index is that it's not tradable
it's not something you can go buy or you
know go short and bet against and robin
hood has told me that they don't plan to
license the index to etf issuers if they
did then one day you would probably be
able to buy a robin hood index etf they
say at this point in time anyway there's
no such plan
why did robin hood say that it was
creating this new index
so robin hood gave two reasons for this
so first of all
they said that their customers like to
know what fellow investors are doing
the other reason is that robinhood is
basically trying to
reshape the pr narrative around the
company and the sort of people who trade
on robin hood
robin hood investors have a reputation
for
piling into kind of volatile risky
stocks and losing a lot of money doing
it and robin hood says that they see
their own data and they think that
that's a false narrative and what
they've decided to do is put out this
index which will show generally speaking
how well robin hood investors are doing
and if anybody asks the question again
about how are they doing you'll just be
able to point to the index
you know in 2018 robin hood released
hourly data on stocks and the stock's
popularity among its customers but then
it shut off that data in the summer of
2020 saying it was worried that that
data could be misconstrued or
misunderstood isn't this essentially the
same thing but instead of hourly updates
they're going to give us monthly updates
so the data you're referring to was
popularized by a website called robin
track that basically gathered it all up
and published it in a fairly easy to use
interface and became fairly popular for
a while in 2020
the original data that robin hood put
out
was every single hour you would get the
actual
total holdings of uh various stocks on
robin hood
and you'd actually see like you know how
many shares were being amassed by the
robin hood user base from that you could
figure out if they're buying or selling
a particular stocks
there were some concerns at the time
that this data was so detailed that
would actually allow
hedge funds to kind of game what was
going on so if they saw that a lot of
retail investors were piling into a
particular stock they could either try
to catch the wave and buy the stock too
or decide that all those retail
investors were dumb and but against them
once this started getting a lot of
attention
robin hood abruptly cut off the data
feed that was providing this
the robin track website still exists but
it basically hasn't been updated since
august 2020 when robin hood cut off the
data i would say this index is fairly
different because the composition is
being only released once a month and
it's kind of somewhat backward looking
you won't have as much of a real-time
sense of what's going on
in addition to that you don't have quite
the same level of granularity about you
know how many shares of stock are held
okay so then big picture you know you've
been speaking with market watchers what
have their reactions to this been so far
do they think it's going to be useful or
not
so i have spoken to a few people about
this and i think that there is some
consensus that it would be it'll be
interesting data because in general
since we've had this force of small
investors coming out and becoming kind
of more influential and you know
swinging the market around there's been
more interest in having metrics to
follow what they're doing how do we get
data on what they're buying what they're
interested what the holdings are and
this will be a picture that will be kind
of a glimpse into that world
provided by robin hood which is one of
the biggest names in this particular
space
that said i wouldn't make an overly big
deal out of it in particular because
there are no plans as yet to launch an
etf based on the data or a fund based on
the data if it were a tradable index
something that people could actually
sort of place bets on then that could
lead to some interesting effects as
you'd see you know hedge funds literally
betting against robin hood investors by
shorting the index uh it doesn't look
like that's going to happen anytime soon
all right that was our reporter
alexander ossopovich alex thank you so
much for breaking this down for us
thanks julie great talking to you
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing for more tech stories check out
our website wsj.com i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]